excited look drop for this we just have
people go directly to the website
Craig veto thank you very much thanks
according to david horowitz 101
left-wing radicals have taken over
departments at universities around the
country are using their positions to
promote their own political agendas the
professor's Monday at 3 p.m. Eastern
human genome project director Francis
Collins argues that god makes science
possible and that science and faith
complement one another in his book the
language of God this talk from politics
and prose bookstore in Washington DC is
just over an hour thank you I'm
delighted to be able to introduce dr.
Collins whom I've known for many years
dr. Collins is many things he's a superb
scientist director for many years of the
human genome project and now director of
the National Center for Human Genome
Research at NIH he's someone who is
deeply and thoughtfully concerned about
the ethical issues and implications of
the genetics research that he has led
for many years and he's an enthusiastic
teacher and scientific leader Francis is
also a committed Christian in a
scientific community not always highly
tolerant of such beliefs to say the
least although I must say when my late
husband was very ill a few years ago he
was a scientist and he was amazed at the
number of people who wrote to him who
were scientists whom he had no idea
believed in God that they kept it on the
quiet francis has written a book that is
a wonderful story of two paths taken one
a path to science and the other path to
God it's a fascinating book and very
well and clearly written and it's a
respectful book it's respectful always
and deeply of science and his colleagues
and science and it's also respectful of
the beliefs and practices of his fellow
Christians
this doesn't mean that it is a book
without strong views and strong opinions
on some of the most contentious debates
of our time especially evolution
although I can't believe I'm even saying
that it is a hotly debated topic it
clearly is it's hard to imagine how many
more tree and fossil shells we need to
really get the belief systems going here
in terms of evolution dr. Collins is
much more tactful than I am some
scientists have said that the last thing
that science needs is more discussion of
religion
fortunately Francis disagrees and is
trying to create a more thoughtful and
tolerant climate for the exchange of
very strong ideas and strong beliefs
finally Francis is a passionate
exuberant man and his book not only
conveys that his wonder at nature has
wondered the beauty of the world the
privilege and delights of being a
scientist but he also makes it clear
that such passion can be directed at God
as well as understanding the laws of
nature dr. Collins
okay thank you so much for an incredibly
generous introduction and for me having
written the first book of my career to
be introduced by somebody who I admire
so much as a writer is really an
incredible compliment I can't imagine
anybody I would rather I have make those
opening remarks and so thank you from
the bottom of my heart and I could tell
from the reaction of the entire group
when you were introduced how much you
are held in high esteem by anybody who
reads books Robert Jastrow the noted
astronomer wrote when a scientist writes
about God his colleagues assume he is
either over the hill or going bonkers I
hope I am neither and yet I have done
that thing I have written about God and
I've written about science how did I
come to write this book is a question
that some have asked me in the last
couple of weeks since it came out and I
was very much influenced by the
experience three years ago of being
asked to give a series of three lectures
in the evening at the Harvard Memorial
Church an endowed lectureship that has
been going on for a hundred years called
the noble lectures which had the
intention of bringing somebody to the
Harvard campus who would reflect upon
some way in which faith was relevant to
the modern world and I was asked to talk
about how faith might be relevant to
science that was a somewhat intimidating
experience I had thought much about
those topics since I became a believer
at age 27 but to put them together in a
fashion that would hopefully achieve
some coherence was another challenge and
I expected perhaps a few dozen students
would turn up and probably drift away
quickly after the topic was fleshed out
well that isn't what happened for three
subsequent consecutive week nights on
cold February evenings in the middle of
Harvard Yard hundreds of Harvard
undergraduates turned out
for a conversation about science and
faith and whether they are in fact
compatible or whether they are
incompatible and they asked penetrating
questions and it was clear to me that
most of the people who were there did
not already have a view on this they
were seekers they were trying to figure
out from their perspective looking at
the data from science and looking at the
evidence of belief what what were their
views going to be what world view would
they choose and it was clear from
conversations with some of them during
and after this that they were hungry for
that kind of conversation now I don't
think Harvard undergraduates although
there are very bright group are
drastically different than the rest of
the world and so it seemed clear that
this is an area where there is a desire
for dialogue and the dialogue has not
necessarily been happening because the
stage has been dominated it seems by the
extreme voices on either end of this
spectrum we have on the one hand some of
my colleagues who as scientists are also
atheists arguing that science
particularly evolution demands atheism
we have on the other end of the spectrum
people of strong religious persuasion
who are convinced of a literality of
Genesis 1 and who therefore do not trust
science to reveal facts about the age of
the universe or the relatedness of
species young people oftentimes caught
in the middle between these extremes
don't know what to do and the message
that I wanted to put forward in this
book is really I hope good news in this
contentious debate and that is that you
don't have to choose between these ways
of finding truth they are different ways
of finding truth incredible value and
that you can be as I am both a rigorous
scientist who demands to see the data
before drawing a conclusion and somebody
who believes in a transcendent God a God
who created the universe and who's
interested in each of us as individuals
how did I get to that path of belief it
was not by having been raised in a
household where faith was practiced
because that was not my story I was
raised in an incredible environment rich
as it was in exposure to the arts
to theater to music but not to faith and
when I got to college in those
late-night conversations and the
dormitories that happen often times at
that point in one's life I became pretty
convinced when we talked about God that
I wasn't interested it was convenient of
course not to be interested I was at
that point in my life where there were
lots of temptations and I was just as
happy to give in to them and not worry
too much about whether there was a
standard that I should be living up to
and then went off to graduate school in
quantum mechanics of all things and I
became convinced that everything could
be reduced to mathematics physics that
anything that really mattered could be
written out as a second-order
differential equation because that's
what you do in quantum mechanics and I
became not just an agnostic but an
atheist and I was pretty obnoxious about
it in fact and it was sort of part of my
job it seemed to on an encounter with
anybody who mentioned something about
faith to point out to them that that was
really a throwback to a past era and
something that they should just get over
but then I had a change in my own path
which was precipitated by a realization
that this particular area of science
that I had chosen as exciting as it was
on a daily basis was maybe not what I
wanted to do for the rest of my life and
that was particularly true because I got
exposed to what was happening in biology
recombinant DNA was just coming along it
was clear that things were happening in
a field that I'd pretty much ignored and
not knowing what else to do
I decided I'd try to keep all my doors
and options open so I went to medical
schools why they let me in is not quite
clear this particular speech about my
desire to be one of the nation's future
doctors must have seemed a little thin
but somehow this was accepted by those
good people at the University of North
Carolina and off I went to learn how to
be a physician and that was gloriously
exciting and I continued my atheist
perspective for a while but then as one
does as a third-year medical student
thrust out into the hospital wards made
to face up to the fact that terrible
things are happening to nice people that
illnesses
that people have done nothing to bring
on themselves are happening right and
left to truly wonderful human beings and
as I tried to help and often couldn't I
got to know some of those good North
Carolina people and some of them told me
about their faith and what an enormous
leap our Falak they felt they were
standing on and that they were ready to
face anything even death
without fear I assumed that was a
psychological crutch but it was
obviously a pretty strong one and that
made me curious and on one afternoon an
elderly woman who had really terrible
heart disease that caused her a great
deal of chest pain on a daily basis that
we weren't doing a very good job of
managing she told me about her faith and
how really this was not something that
she was fearing although we had nothing
much to offer her and she turned to me
and looked me square in the face and she
said what do you believe
I hope somebody asks all of us that at
some point because you kind of need to
be able to ask yourself that question in
the context of it being asked by another
person and I stammered and I stuttered
and you know I had my atheist
perspective but suddenly it felt very
thin and I said I guess I don't know and
I walked out of the room and I was
troubled and I remain troubled for the
next several days because I began to
realize that I had done something a
scientist is not supposed to do I had
drawn a conclusion about a really
important question is there a god
without looking at the evidence
scientists aren't supposed to do that
right and I realized I'd never given a
moment's consideration to the arguments
for and against I assumed there just
weren't any arguments for and the only
people who believed were those who had
arrived at that conclusion because of
family upbringing or culture and I
realized if I'm gonna be an atheist I've
got to be a better atheist I've got to
be able to defend my atheism better than
I did that afternoon so off I went to
try to learn about what faith was all
about and I found it all very confusing
and so I went to visit with a minister
who lived down the street in Carrboro
North Carolina and I asked him to
explain something to me about this and I
asked him all sorts of questions and
many of which were probably blasphemous
and he patiently tried to answer some of
them and said you know I see where
you're coming from and you are somebody
who really is looking for some kind of
logical explanation for why faith could
be a reasonable perspective for a
thinking person I have just the book for
you and he took a little book off of his
shelf and he said go home and read this
the book was mere Christianity CS
Lewis's incredibly thoughtful incredibly
well argued treatise on the plausibility
of faith and as I turned the pages of
that book all of my arguments against
God lay in ruins by about page three and
I realize just how much those arguments
had been based on really naive schoolboy
ideas and as I got deeper into the book
I begin to be convinced that while
rational argument cannot bring you all
the way to becoming a believer you could
certainly go down that path to the point
of admitting and I had to admit that
belief in God was more plausible more
rational than saying I know there is no
God that became the least rational of
the choices because that assumes you
know enough to be able to say despite
the limits in my understanding I can be
absolutely certain that there is no God
that hit me between the eyes as a
position that a thinking person really
should not take without committing an
enormous act of arrogance and hubris but
I didn't like that conclusion and I was
particularly troubled because Louis
seemed to be reading my mind every time
I would come up with an argument that
challenged what he had said on page 29
while on page 30 he would come back at
me with why my argument actually had a
hole in it and I began to realize why
that was because here was a man who had
travelled the same path that I had an
Oxford scholar who was a committed
atheist and who said about to try to
shore up his atheism and accidentally
converted himself
and that's what happened to me I was
particularly convinced by this argument
and I remain convinced by it today when
it comes to the existence of the moral
law this knowledge of right and wrong
that we all have that is characteristic
of our species human beings and what you
do not find in other animals on our
planet this knowledge which we all have
and which we try sometimes to listen to
and sometimes choose to ignore is
something which from my perspective is
somebody who studies evolution and DNA
cannot be fully understood on the basis
of those arguments because you see the
moral law sometimes calls me to do
things that are not good for my
propagation of my DNA think about it
we're the people we most admire there
are people who have done sacrificial
acts who have put their very lives in
danger to help others mother Teresa
Oskar Shindler those are people who we
consider to have represented sort of the
pinnacle of human noble action the
altruistic effort the agape that Luis
talks about the kind of love that seeks
no recompense that is purely a love that
wishes to help others without
expectation of benefit what is that all
about evolution would not expect that
evolution is all about whether that
individual is going to propagate their
DNA or not if I'm walking down the river
and I see somebody out there drowning
and I'm not a good swimmer evolution is
going to tell me move on if that person
is my worst enemy they're particularly
gonna evolution will say move on you win
but that's not what I feel in my heart
it's not what any of us do there is that
still small voice that calls you to do
something sacrificial and I find out a
very compelling signpost towards the
possibility of a God who not only
created the universe but who has an
interest in us as human being and who
stands in for what is good and holy so
this is not a deist God
the theists God who cares about human
beings those arguments from me were
incredibly compelling at age 27 but I
resisted and I had many doubts and I ran
away as fast as I could but ultimately I
couldn't run fast enough and that need
to face up to this reality overtook me
after many months of studying various
religions of the world I became quite
taken by the fact that the person of
Jesus Christ was a special kind of faith
because of his claim to be God no other
faith made that outrageous claim and I
couldn't see how you could both call him
a great teacher and say he wasn't who he
said he was and so while I recognize
that every person has their own path to
travel here and this may not be the path
for many of you for me that became a
compelling argument and ultimately I
became a Christian at age 28 but can a
geneticist be a believer well happily
I'm here to say yes and I'm not the only
one fact a poll was taken of working
scientists a few years ago where they
asked the following question do you
believe in a God to whom one may pray in
expectation of an answer that was the
question they had asked that same
question in 1916 40 percent of working
scientists said yes in 1916 in 1997 they
asked that question 40 percent said yes
does that surprise you
where are all of those people because
they are not exactly uh sharing that
information and you know why it's
because I don't think the scientific
community is particularly welcoming to
those kinds of discussions there's sort
of an unwritten taboo you can talk about
almost anything that has to do with a
natural world but oh please let's not go
into the spiritual stuff they might
think we've gone soft
scientists have a rigorous approach to
understanding things in nature and
things outside of nature really don't
fit that mode and so quite appropriately
science is not the way to understand
those
and we scientists therefore just don't
talk about them but there are lots of
people who believe as I do a cigar
who is the major proponent of Darwinism
in the United States shortly after the
publication of the Origin of Species was
a devout believer theodosius dobzhansky
one of the best-known evolutionists of
the 20th century was a devout Greek
Orthodox a believer these are compatible
views and yet that seems in many ways to
have faded away in the current often
shrill debate about whether science is
compatible with faith what do we learn
from the genome about this it has been
my great privilege to lead thousands of
scientists in six countries over the
course of 13 years to read out our own
instruction book all of the 3 billion
letters of our DNA code now laid out
there on the Internet in highly accurate
form in order to enable us to go to this
next step which we're now very much into
of understanding how that works and how
it can play a role in developing better
methods of disease prevention and cure
and that is a very exciting interval
indeed that we're into I can tell you
that by studying our DNA and comparing
that with many other organisms which we
are now able to do we have genome
sequences on more than 30 different
species now the argument in favor of the
relatedness of living species by descent
from a common ancestor is overwhelming
and one cannot explain really of what we
see in the genome by any other means
that of course is a terribly distressing
statement for some believers who are
attached to a literal interpretation of
Genesis one that argues that humans and
other species were created by multiple
acts of special creation as opposed to
coming about by an evolutionary path but
I do not see why that conclusion is
required by a reading of the text I am a
devout believer in what the Bible tells
us but I don't think Genesis 1 was
intended to be a scientific textbook and
I'm not alone in that I take comfort in
the
writings of st. Augustine who had in 400
AD before there was any reason to worry
about evolution and to be apologetic
about his opinion I wrote very
compellingly after considering Genesis
no less than five books about it and in
each of those after wrestling with
possible interpretations he comes to the
conclusion that really no human could
know exactly what the writer of Genesis
presumably Moses intended to convey in
those opening verses and that in
Augustine's words very explicitly we
believers should not attach ourselves so
strongly to a single interpretation of
those particular verses that subsequent
discoveries would cause that to be
overturned and cause us and our faith to
be put to scorn words which I think we
really have to pay attention to all too
often I think believers in an attempt to
try to demonstrate their sincere
dedication and devotion to their Lord
have attached themselves to narrow
perspectives on particular scriptural
interpretations which were not necessary
by the original language of the text and
which when subsequently shown to have
cracks in them on the basis of
scientific advances do not do damage to
science they do damage to faith
intelligent design a recent arrival on
the scene in this debate about evolution
and whether it can account for human
beings
once again I fear has stepped into this
a particular territory of postulating a
God of the gaps the supernatural need
for intervention in the evolutionary
process in order to explain some of
these very complex molecular machines
that we find within all living organisms
but already the cracks in that argument
are showing from the scientific
investigations of just the last couple
of years I would therefore really as a
believer in a scientist hope that we
wouldn't step into that particular way
of thinking because it does not only
create this kind of tension between
scientists and believers it actually I
think places faith at some risk of
having been attached to a particular
network framework that turns out not to
be justifiable once more data is
accumulated and
it's unnecessary so how do I put this
together you may be wondering okay this
is fine he says he's a scientist he says
he's a believer in a transcendent God
how's that work well here's how it works
for me I do believe that God created the
universe that amazing flash of energy 14
billion years ago that screams out for
an explanation about how could something
be created out of nothing
I believe that God did that creative
action with intentions not just to have
some rocks and some gas floating around
the universe but the intention to have
creatures marvelous diversity of
creatures including one special type of
creature with whom he could have
relationship that would be us I believe
that God chose the mechanism of
evolution in order to accomplish that
goal and what may seem to us as a random
process that took a very long time did
not seem that way to God who is not
limited by the tyranny of this linear
axis of time that we are and so in that
very moment that very flash of the
creation of the universe God's vision
also included human beings arriving on
the scene in all of our fallen nature it
included having a special relationship
with us infusing us with this moral law
this knowledge of right and wrong that
makes us different from all other
creatures in which evolution alone does
not seem capable of explaining infusing
us if you'll allow the theological term
with a soul and giving us the
opportunity to practice free will which
we have regularly done in ways that are
against his will and which have caused
untold suffering amongst our own peoples
but which in fact is part of the plan
now everything I have just said for me
fits what I know is a scientist and fits
what I know is a believer and I find
this kind of harmonious synthesis
enormous ly satisfying because it makes
my experience as a scientist one where
in investigating the natural world I am
also in some small way getting little
glimpses
into God's mind and if you'll allow it
that means for a believer doing science
is also doing worship that you are not
only learning things about the
mechanical aspects of what we see around
us but you are also learning something
about the awesome genius of the one who
made it so I find that to be a wonderful
way to spend my time now some have
argued that these have to be
non-overlapping magisteria as Steve and
Jay Gould said that you need to keep
your spiritual worldview over here and
your scientific worldview over there
because if they happen to get together
at the same moment your brain would
explode well mine's not exploding right
now and they are both coexisting and
they do so most of the time I do think
we have to be careful in that situation
when you're asking a question to be sure
what kind of question it is and which of
these worldviews is most likely to give
you an answer but to my scientific
colleagues who say the only questions
worth asking are ones that science can
answer I would say that doesn't quite
work for me what about the question
what's my purpose in life what about the
question why are we all here
what about the question is there a god
what about that question what happens
after we die is it not clear that
science offers you nothing in terms of
answers to those questions and either
you decide as some scientists have done
that they're just out of order and we
shouldn't go there or you have to
develop some other pathway towards
finding the answers and for me that
pathway is the one that has been
travelled down through the centuries by
minds much greater than mine that have
sought to seek through spiritual means
answers to questions that only come by
finding a relationship with God so to
conclude before we take some questions
here I think it is a great tragedy that
we have had such a polarized
circumstance particularly in the last
few years that the stage has been so
dominated by the shrill voices that
claim there can be no
rapprochement between these particular
perspectives some of my own colleagues
who say that because of evolution
atheism has to be the only choice of a
thinking person again I would argue that
that is the least rational of all
choices and to my my fellow believers
for whom I have great respect who have
argued that because evolution is not
compatible with their current view of
Genesis 1 that it must be wrong I beg
you to think of the consequences of
taking that stand and think of those
young people at Harvard who are trying
to figure out where they want to place
their faith and their beliefs for the
future they will not be attracted to a
faith that denies a vast array of
scientific data they will not be
attracted to a faith that says well you
know the data is there but it's really
there because God put in some evidence
to try to fool us and test our faith
does that sound like the kind of God
that one would want to worship who
becomes a cosmic trickster who basically
sets things up so that the universe
looks as if it's 14 billion years old
when it's really only 6,000 that doesn't
seem like a compatible position and yet
I've heard that position put forward and
I know as I say those things that sounds
harsh and I do not mean to be I really
have great compassion and understanding
for the sincere views of many believers
who are concerned that if you start
tinkering with any aspect of the literal
interpretation of any verse then you're
starting down a slippery slope that will
throw out faith altogether but you know
we're mature adults we live on slippery
slopes all the time when you look at the
words of the Bible there are parts of it
which are clearly the record of
eyewitnesses and we better not tinker
with those that's talking about history
and that's most of the New Testament for
me but when you look at job or you look
at Jonah or in fact you look at Genesis
it is not clear to a sincere believer
exactly how much of this is intended to
be literal truth and how much is to
teach us about God's character and about
his plans for all of us and in those
circumstances attaching myself to a God
I would say we would be better off to
anchor our faith in the love and grace
of God and not in some narrow
interpretation of a small part of these
holy scriptures that we're fortunate
enough to have in front of us so in this
book I try to put forward that kind of a
synthesis I don't expect it will be for
everyone if it in a small way starts
some conversations that weren't
happening in all kinds of venues the
scientific seminar rooms maybe a little
bit the churches maybe a little bit the
coffee houses the book stores like this
one maybe a little bit then I will feel
it was worth the task but I don't want
any more of those Harvard undergraduates
or all the ones like them to feel that
nobody's talking about this and I would
give one more exhortation and that what
is what this book is really trying to do
that we should be discussing these
issues if we're interested in truth
there are all kinds of ways of finding
it we're interested in knowing science
is not the only way to do that if we're
interested in being whole creatures not
just mechanically oriented individuals
then science and spirit have a great
deal to offer us to live out that fully
experienced a kind of human life for me
anyway that has been an amazing gift an
amazing surprise and one that I deeply
cherish I thank you all for your
attention I'd be glad to answer
questions
and as was said at the beginning if you
have questions please come to the
microphone here so that they can be
heard especially by the folks who are
listening on c-span yes sir hi I would
love to see you in a debate with Richard
Dawkins someday and we'll be here in
October I think with his new book the
question is Daniel Dennett recently put
out a new book called breaking a spell
and he was here and spoke to us and he
hmm I don't know what to do do we have
any technical advice here about how the
microphone could acquire some volume
maybe it's on but not I start over yeah
start over I'm not sure everybody could
hear I would say I would like to see you
in a debate with Richard Dawkins someday
I know Richard quite well and we've had
conversations and it'd be a great event
to see I think my question is about
Daniel Dennett's new book breaking the
spell who was here this year talking
about it and as a scientist I think he
challenges humans and all of us
especially scientists to examine
religion and try to understand it as a
human event as a human behavior to
understand it because it's so impacting
upon our lives now as a scientist what
do you think of his call for humanity to
actually examine this thing that impacts
our lives and our culture and our future
so dramatically so who could argue with
the premise that something is important
as faith ought to be subjected to
discussion and close scrutiny where I
depart from Dennett is that his
presumption is from the beginning as an
atheist as he is that the way in which
one scrutinizes faith is to basically
demonstrate how it is a purely human
invention that is his premise and he
argues that we should come up with other
ways of conducting research that would
demonstrate that to be correct his
particular perspective does not allow
the possibility that there might
actually be eternal truth hiding within
these faiths which he views as a purely
human social invention
brought forward by years of culture and
maybe even by some evolutionary
advantages although I think those turn
out to be the kind of just so stories
that don't hold up very well when
subjected to scrutiny the Western world
largely having developed in the
judeo-christian tradition how now do we
best incorporate Islam Judaism Buddhism
into our framework so that's a great
question and one that has no easy answer
I must say although I'm not an expert in
all of the faces that you just mentioned
I have studied all of them to some
degree and it seems to me that the great
religions of the world have a great deal
in common and I think they would not
have long survived if they did not they
hold within them the kind of truths that
are eternal that are going to stand the
test of time no matter what else happens
in our world they do obviously have
differences I think if we could spend a
little more time focused on the areas of
commonality and their very major instead
of focused on the specific areas of
difference we might have a better chance
of understanding each other my own faith
pathway led me to Christianity that is
for me the faith that had the greatest
meaning and which I now ascribe to as a
way of finding truth but I know that is
a very personal kind of pathway and I
would just urge anybody who hasn't
actually looked at that comparison to do
so and see where you come out nobody can
really tell you what their answer is you
have to find that one yourself yes hi
I'm speaking one from one of those great
faiths I'm rabbi Lynn Landsberg hi and I
used to be the rabbi in Stan Virginia
right around the corner from where you
grew up indeed and but when you talk
about the Creator God you talk about you
sound like you can be coming from
somebody from the Talmud or the Mishnah
because you discussed about how we think
how how existence versus sacrifice is
know then what evolution versus
sacrifices is just doesn't work for us
it's sacrifice comes first evolution
comes second and that said to Jewish way
of thinking
so my question is um is it linguistics
or the fact that you said God is a he
that I your point is very well taken and
I probably need to acquire a better
linguistic style in this regard because
I know that is the use of a personal
pronoun in a way that some people are
troubled and offended by and I by no
means I mean to commit that kind of
error it is one of those manners of
speech that I don't seem to have quite
managed to rewire my brain for so when I
say he please assume that I am talking
about Almighty God whose gender I do not
know you're a great tutor okay I'll sign
up I also have taken a journey similar
to yours but have come to slightly
different conclusions I mean there may
very well be something like
consciousness maybe a dimension for
example in other words the problem I
have with standardized religions is not
to reject them it's just it's too hard a
packaging of what this greater
consciousness may be I mean we talked
about the morality of God but if you
look around the animals eating the
animals that's pretty nasty business
going on out there
after survived so what I'm suggesting
I'd like to hear your comment on today
is that that we don't necessarily have
to arrive at the traditional point but
we should be using science and all the
religious thinking of the past to
possibly reconsider what the
possibilities are for this higher energy
and and not try to stamp it as though we
absolutely know not to anthropomorphize
it but just to to take science take the
tradition and allow ourselves the
openness to to possibly go forward with
something that might need some adjusting
I think many people are on that path
towards incorporating all kinds of
perspectives and new information into
trying to understand what that entity is
that we call spirit and I can only tell
you in my own path that has been a
journey that I'm still on I think
anybody who is a believer who tells you
I've got all the answers now is probably
stuck somewhere that they ought not to
be we all have to grow and develop in
this regard I will say though that I do
believe that ultimately there is truth
in there somewhere and the effort that
all of us should seek out is to find
what really is the truth of the matter
is difficult as that may be and and for
me I think the truth comes partly from
these philosophical and theological
arguments in a general abstract sense
and they come partly from having access
to texts that have been down through the
ages given the stamp of spiritual
authority that I think it does not come
by accident but actually represents
something very significant and putting
those things together here's where I am
but I think as you point out we probably
ought not to be stuck in any particular
place and be absolutely confident that's
the whole answer yes sir with the
thousands of galaxies and thousands of
bodies and so on our solar system is
such an inconsequential thing and our
planet and that the little speck and
human beings on that it was that
specifically chosen human being are we
the only beneficiaries of this endowment
from God I don't know if you couldn't
hear the question yet the question is if
if the earth is such a small speck in
the scale of the universe as it is are
we the only creatures that have been
specially chosen by God are we all there
is I don't know the answer to that
there's a lot of people interested in
searching for life on other planets
there's the famous Drake Equation that
goes through a calculation of how like
that would be that there would be life
intelligent life in other places that we
might ultimately be able to make contact
with and unfortunately the various
coefficients in that equation are not
possible to really define you have to
guess at them and so you could have all
kinds of wildly different answers
depending on your guesses as to the
coefficients to me that's a very
interesting question both scientifically
and in terms of our understanding of our
place in the universe but it's not a
question that would I think threaten my
faith if the answer came out one way or
the other if Almighty God decided
through the process of creating the
universe and all of the things that we
know about our in our planet to create
human life why could he not do the same
thing in some other location would that
dilute him would he be too busy to keep
track on that doesn't seem to me like
something that would be a problem for
Almighty God there may be other places
where other intelligent beings like us
with other model forces I think that's
possible I think that's possible by the
way I didn't mention it but since we're
talking about our small place in the
universe one thing that I find
particularly compelling as a scientist
in terms of the idea of God the Creator
is this whole argument about how
incredibly unlikely it is that our
universe came to be if you look at the
constants in cosmology and physics that
are basically set at the value they have
there's no theory that can determine
them things like the weak and strong
nuclear force or the force of gravity
and you imagine what would have happened
after the Big Bang if you had tweaked
those constants by even in one case one
part in 10 to the 14th which would be a
hundred million million if you changed
that constant by just that amount then
either the universe would have gone on
expanding forever without any
coalescence of gas and stars and planets
or it would have come back together
again so quickly the Big Bang would have
been followed by a Big Crunch that there
would not have been any opportunity for
life to come to pass I think that's
fascinating we live on this knife edge
of improbable or the Big Crunch
well people argue about that I don't
think we'll be here to watch
yes thank you for sharing your faith
story and noticed that the subtitle of
your book describes the evidence for
belief and you mentioned CS Lewis who
certainly takes a logicians approach to
faith in his opening chapters and I'm
wondering how you would respond to
people who say that faith ought to be a
leap and not based on evidence or logic
or those sorts of more deductive
reasoning that's a great question and I
think both are right I think logic for a
person who thinks in those particular
kinds of arguments as many scientists do
is a critical first step if you are at a
place where you have to say to yourself
belief in God is completely irrational
it's going to be tough for you if you're
a rational person to get there so for me
the argument that Lewis is putting
forward in the in in his book and many
others have written about this as well
brought me to the point from pure logic
of saying the existence of God is
plausible but that's not faith yet that
is sort of preparing the ground that is
getting you to the point where you say
okay I don't have to commit intellectual
suicide to be a believer which is what
some of my colleagues have been telling
me all these years actually it's
possible to be an intellectually
consistent and fulfilled believer but I
still am NOT a believer until I take
that leap that leap is called faith and
there's no substitute for it if we could
prove God's existence we would all be
subscribers to a consistent faith and
we're obviously not and science isn't
going to get you there and so while you
may argue yourself right up to the edge
of the cliff you still have to decide
whether you're gonna leap and in fact it
was that fear of leaping that held me
back for a good year before finally
taking that step a step that I have
never regretted thanks
the doctor that leads into my question
about taking the next step of never
regretting it I was would be interested
in knowing whether you paid any
significant professional price for
coming forward with your profession of
Christianity and if so what was it I
don't really think I have although some
have likened to writing this book to
taking a public bath because it is a
kind of personal revelation that
scientists don't usually engage in
especially when it comes to this topic
of belief most of my colleagues I think
are very respectful of this perspective
as I said a 40% of them actually agree
with it and I've gotten many responses
and emails from people in that category
saying thank you for saying openly what
we all believe but are a little
inhibited about speaking about because
of our concerns about how that will be
received by our colleagues I think it
has probably been helpful to me to have
thought about this for a long time I've
never been quiet about my faith but
certainly not this open about it and and
perhaps it would be more difficult at an
earlier point in one's career where
you're worried about getting tenure and
worried about how sort of how you're
going to be viewed in the scheme of
things that you're trying to build your
own scientific reputation maybe I'm just
old enough now to be able not to care
quite as much about that my question has
to do with theism versus deism yeah I
was very interested in the part of your
talk in which you try to reconcile the
science and the faith and I was just
wondering about whether that really
washes what you said on the one hand you
said there was an intentionality of the
God the Creator associated with the Big
Bang and that intentionality involved a
being that evolved into one that knew
right from wrong and can make choices
accordingly on the other hand theism
attaches itself to the notion of
imminence
if that intentionality was already posed
at the beginning and involved
intentionally in evolution that was
already set in motion at the beginning
where does that leave the notion of
imminence so will you define imminence
for the group that may not be as
familiar with that term and define it
for me too to be sure you're using it
the same way I do
the presence of the ideological things
that we might all know the presence of
God in the present yes so why can God
not be in the present and also at the
moment of creation this is something I
tried to say but maybe didn't say very
well we as human beings are limited in
our understanding of how things work by
the fact that yesterday came before
today which will come before tomorrow
God if God has any significance and
you're not a pantheist then God is
outside of nature and it seems to me
therefore plausible that God is also not
limited by this axis of time if that is
a correct assumption then God can both
be there at the moment of creation
knowing its outcome and also be here
watching that outcome unfold and that
might seem like a tough sort of
headache-inducing concept for us because
we're so limited in that perspective but
I actually find that resolves a lot of
the issues of theistic evolution which
both allows God to have a plan a grand
loving benevolent plan but also to be
working in each of our lives in a way
that we have the chance to interact with
him dr. Kahn's you spoke beautifully
about how religion and science can and
should coexist but last week we saw how
they don't always and there's a
dialectic between the two um I want to
ask you specifically about President
Bush's veto of stem-cell additional
stem-cell research and I want to ask you
about the the broader question of
whether government and religion should
be influenced what can and cannot be
done in scientific research so I'm a
government employee
I wrote this book is what we call an
outside activity so in the in the book I
actually have an appendix that talks
about bioethical issues and has a whole
section on stem cells so now as a
outside activity person I'll answer your
question I think we've had a great deal
of heat on the topic of stem cells and
the scientific issues have often gotten
lost in that heat for me I think the
union of sperm and egg the opportunity
for a human life to come into being is a
very significant moment and deserves
serious moral consideration at the same
time I do believe there's a great
promise medically for the scientific
investigation of embryonic stem cells I
have a hard time understanding why it is
more ethical therefore to have hundreds
of thousands of frozen embryos sitting
in freezers which have no chance of ever
being reimplantation scens disease or
diabetes or a long list of other
disorders I also think we've made a big
mistake in the terms of mixing together
two very different ways of creating a
stem cell one being the union of sperm
and egg in the usual fashion to make an
embryo the other being this really
remarkable thing called somatic cell
nuclear transfer where we take the
nucleus from one of your skin cells
which has your whole DNA sequence in it
all of our cells have the whole book and
you convince it to go back in time and
to become able to make other types of
cells that is not something that happens
in nature it is not something that in my
mind has the same moral status as the
union of sperm and egg and yet we have
equated those things in our arguments
and we've called both of them embryos
and we've used horrible words like
cloning to describe the second one of
those and we've really tangled ourselves
up in our terminology I wish we could
step back which is probably not
realistic now from the current very
dug-in positions and they got very dug
in very early here and really look at
the scientific differences between those
things and have a more serious
discussion about
whether from whatever perspective you're
standing those are in fact deserving of
the same kind of moral status that's
currently being applied but I'm probably
being a little optimistic to think in
the current climate that we're going to
have that conversation anytime soon yep
this is a semi hostile question but
thank you for warning me but what yeah
what part of being a scientist would you
regard as being most supportive of being
a believer and what part of being a
scientist is sort of gets most in the
way I mean I'm thinking oh I'll just be
really fun about that the average
scientist has a lot of moral and
sensitivity toward other people they
just you know they're they are every bit
as motivated as the CEO of a fortune 500
company except those guys are lazy in
comparison from what I've observed so
anyway I don't want to bias your answer
but I look at those oh I've got time I'm
not thinking about necessarily into any
kind of intellectual thing but something
that goes with the practice of
scientists just from your perspective so
I actually think for the most part
scientists are not quite as you
described they're people who are often
motivated very much at their core about
a desire to discover things about the
world and many of them work in
biomedical research are motivated by the
desire to help people and I think in
that regard that motivation is very
close to the same mandate for healing
that many believers feel as well so I
think the part of a scientist that is in
some way by some inner drive determined
to make the world a better place is the
same kind of motivation that many
believers have and is a chance for the
two to get together and agree quite
strongly the part of a scientist that
gets in a way I think is the mindset
which is part of our training that you
really are not going to be interested in
studying anything for which you cannot
collect rigorous data and that if you
carry to an extreme basically rules out
any consideration of the spiritual out
of hand and that is an unfortunate
extension of what should be rigorous
thinking about nature to say that's all
there is
and you become not then a scientist but
a materialist and I think that is the
kind of risk that many scientists have
fallen into and frankly I think when you
look at scientific beliefs as I said 40
percent of believers to the other 60%
say they're atheists no I think a lot of
them simply haven't thought about it
it's like we're all so busy and there
are so many other things to do and the
topic makes you vaguely uncomfortable
and you know I'll put that off and maybe
someday when I'm retired I'll give it
some thought well God doesn't always
give you the chance so again I would
hope as as I have said in the book that
amongst scientists we could have those
conversations a little more often and
that we would consider the possibility
that a fully experienced life could
include that perspective and not just
the materialist view I see I'm getting
the high sign two more questions yes
please hi I had a journey that was the
exact opposite of yours I grew up with a
lot of religious training and in my
teenage years rejected God and for
several reasons and I'd like to bounce
them off you because their reasons that
even in my adulthood I still believe and
one is it's very hard for me to accept a
God who is the source of morality as you
believe who would allow so much
suffering in the world the other one is
just more one of logic and as a
scientist I'd be interested to hear your
analysis of it if you say that the world
is so complex that it must have been
created by a Supreme Being then in my
teenage years I was like well then who
created God and that's still something I
don't think that believers have found an
answer to so I'd be interested to hear
your yeah those are great questions I
think the question of suffering is one
which haunts all believers and
non-believers why does this happen
and I think it gets in the way of many
people accepting the idea of a loving
God the argument goes like this if God
was perfectly loving he would want his
creatures to be happy if God was
all-powerful
he would be able to make that happen but
the creatures aren't happy
so either God is not loving or not
powerful or both but there's a flaw in
that argument I mean it assumes the
premise that our most appropriate
experience on the planet is to be happy
all the time
that God is this benevolent grand father
who at the end of every day would say
everyone had a good time and that would
be enough but is that really God's plan
for us first of all let me say an awful
lot of the suffering we experience
occurs because of actions of our own
people and we can't blame God if in the
process of our being granted free will
we choose to use it in ways that hurt
other people and you can't expect God to
suddenly jump in many times a day and
prevent that from happening but there
are certainly instances where people
suffer for reasons that are hard to
blame on any other human being what is
that all about there are no easy answers
to that I actually go into that quite a
bit in chapter 2 of this book and and
and let me say one answer to this which
is a hard one it's a hard one for me is
is that God's purposes extend beyond
ours and one of God's priorities is for
us to get to know him and if God
whispers to us when things are going
well he shouts when things are going
badly as Lewis says suffering is God's
megaphone to rouse a deaf world and if
the most important priority while we're
here on this planet is to find out who
he is and who we are and perhaps to
prepare for something else then the
absence of suffering is probably not the
way to get there and I recognize that
that is not an easy concept to accept
but I've certainly been true in my own
life the times I have grown the most are
the times when really bad things were
happening and I had to come to grips
with what really matters and where the
rocks are that I can stand on and not
the times where things are going
swimmingly and I can pretty much say I'm
in control here I can handle whatever
comes along when things are going badly
I know that's not true and I think we
all know that's not true in terms of
your second question about about God's
who created him again it comes back to
this issue of time the reason we are
demanding to say what created the
universe is because the universe
the laws of time and there had to be a
beginning 14 billion years ago and we
cannot imagine what came before that but
God is outside of those rules and so it
seems to me God is also outside of the
rule of having to have someone create
him all of those arguments we make about
sort of something having to be before
and something else having to be after do
not apply to the supernatural God that I
worship and that solves the problem for
me although I grant you it still puts
you into a metaphysical realm that many
can debate about for a long time last
question I just wanted to make a comment
and also ask you a question the comment
is I don't think it's the conflict
between atheism and the religion is
solely between God and science if you
add up all the scientists from the
beginning of time
most of most of them probably were
religious and believed in some kind of
God
yes and and scientists like you said a
lot of scientists still believe in God
but a lot of atheists know nothing about
science or in a profound way so it's not
that science is just disproving God or
the other way around you can run PCR or
do high-throughput microarrays without
any opinion about whether it's a
Christian God or Islam God or whatever
God absolutely true five all time yeah
so I don't think a scientist is in some
way compares impairing his career for by
believing God believing in some kind of
God but so my question is more so I
don't see this as sort of this Altima
fight between science or religion but my
question is more practical because
nowadays if you don't I guess if you're
not a religious charity then you don't
get the tax dollar
or if you're not and TechStars from
other you know people who don't believe
in Christian God as well so so I'm sorry
what's what's the question but my
question is more practical as a
physician what do you think about
pharmacists and medical doctors who
refuse to prescribe morning-after pills
birth control etc in rural areas where
there is limited medical access because
of their faith okay we got there uh
that's a very difficult area I don't
know that I have an easy answer I would
certainly be sympathetic in both
instances with the people who need those
services but also I'd be very
sympathetic with somebody who's a
caregiver who has a strong moral stance
that they should not be required to do
something which in their view violates
that moral stance so I think we have a
certain obligation to protect that as
well
obviously if we had a better health care
system where people had access more
easily to healthcare broadly across the
nation that would be less of an issue I
take your earlier point to that the
perceived battle between us between
faith and atheism is not one that is
solely conducted on scientific grounds
but I do think in the current Wars at
least as I see them that science is
being used particularly as a weapon from
the atheistic perspective by many
individuals Dawkins was mentioned
earlier certainly he would make that
argument I'm sure he will when he comes
to talk about his book The God Delusion
his you can tell where that's going so
and I will admit that I'm a scientist
this is the world I live in this is
where I see the battles these are the
battles that break my heart these are
the battles that I see young people
particularly in college faced with
courses in biology but also faced with
the great religious traditions and led
to believe that they have to pick
between the two because they can't both
be right that's what upsets me that's
what breaks my heart that's the sort of
circumstance we're in right now which I
hope we can get past so let me just
conclude by reading you the
paragraph of the last chapter here
because it's all about that it's very
brief it is time to call a truce in the
escalating war between science and
spirit the war was never really
necessary
like so many earthly wars this one has
been initiated and intensified by
extremists on both sides sounding alarms
that predict imminent ruin unless the
other side is vanquished science is not
threatened by God it is enhanced God is
most certainly not threatened by science
he made it all possible so let us
together seek to reclaim the solid
ground of an intellectually and
spiritually satisfying synthesis of all
great truths that ancient motherland of
reason and worship was never in danger
of crumbling it never will be it beckons
all sincere seekers of truth to come and
take up residence there
answer that call abandoned the
battlements our hopes joys and the
future of our world depend on it thank
you all very much